le salon
facecelook ça fait 5 ans qu'il est
ouvert donc 3 ans et demi du côté
esthétique et un an et demi côté
coiffure ce qui fait le point fort de
notre de notre salon effectivement c'est
le côté l'épilation au fil donc c'est
une technique qui est aujourd'hui pas
mal demandée et que les nos clientes
apprécient dans le contexte de une
journée bien-être la personne elle peut
faire un soin du visage elle peut se
faire une des mains se faire maquiller
coiffer donc pour justement sortir
pourquoi pas le soir et justement
surprendre ben son homme rentrant chez
elle
voilà le poste à pourvoir donc pour
cette pour cette personne ce que je
recherche c'est justement quelqu'un qui
soit dynamique et qui a cette esprit
d'équipe donc parce que c'est super
important de se sentir bien dans dans un
salon ce sera une une coiffeuse qui qui
aura que le but de du côté coiffure pas
pas d'esthétique l'ambiance de travail
chez face look
donc concerne le sourire l'accueil la
personne donc elle aura comme tâche donc
de gérer l'accueil téléphonique de sa sa
clientèle le son poste de travail si
vous voyez à travers ce poste donc
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer votre
candidature et nous ferons un plaisir de
de vous donner une
réponse vos missions chez
Facel assurer l'accueil physique et
téléphonique de la clientèle réaliser
les coupes et brushing effectuer les
soins et traitement capillaires gérer
votre poste de travail pour postuler
vous devez impérativement être titulaire
d'un CAP
coiffure
le coiffeur ou la coiffeuse doit savoir
exercer un diagnostic capillaire
connaître les tendances mode en matière
de coiffure maîtriser les techniques de
coupe coloration et coiffure avoir la
fibre commercial et savoir être à
l'écoute et conseiller la
clientèle